and coming soon to North Las Vegas a new  born and raised bar this will be their  third site in the valley but the first  2.0 location one of several new eateries  opening on Craig Road in North Las Vegas  this location is meant to uniquely pay  tribute to Veterans and those working at  Nellis Air Force Base just a few miles  east on Craig  we want to let them know that we have  their back we thank them for what they  do every day that's the least we can do  for them putting their lives on the line  for us  the location features a military-themed  war room inside plus several other  military nods it is set to open up in  early January just a couple weeks away